un spécialiste du décryptage des grandes
surfaces ce professeur très réputé a
étudié dans les moindres détails la
stratégie de vente d'ingvar kamprad en
passant des jours a observé ses plans
ceci est le plan d'un magasin ikea au
nord de londres
au départ voilà ce qu'il a intrigué en
tant qu architecte
ils trouvaient leur plan
particulièrement compliqué la première
fois que j'ai mis les pieds dans un
magasin ikea
j'étais complètement perdu un peu
déboussolés je n'arrivais pas à
comprendre comment il était possible de
faire du shopping en étant totalement
désorienté et le professeur a constaté
que dans ce labyrinthe les clients
emprunter pourtant tous exactement le
même chemin indiqué par ikea et selon
lui c'est pour leur faire acheter plus
d'articles
j'ai eu quand même vous venez en ayons
une idée précise de ce que vous voulez
acheter quand je mets comme je ne
pouvais pas trouver tout de suite votre
article parce que vous êtes perdus et
bien vous passez devant plein de choses
dont vous n'auriez pas imaginer avoir
besoin lorsque vous les voyez j'aimerais
bien en avoir un alors vous le mettez
dans votre un parcours imposé une idée
que quand prada copier à new york
en visitant ce musée d'art contemporain
le musée guggenheim à l' architecture
spectaculaire
le bâtiment est entièrement circulaire
et ceci pour guider les visiteurs à
travers un parcours unique qui leur
permet de voir l'ensemble des
chefs-d'oeuvre sans en rater un seul en
reprenant l'idée du parcours imposé
quand prades va faire exploser ses
ventes dans son étude publiée en 2011 à
l'antenne estime que 67 % des produits
que vous achetez dans ses magasins le
sont de manière compulsive
c'est à dire qu'il n'était pas prévu sur
votre liste mais alors comment ikea ci
prend elle pour nous mener ainsi par le
bout du nez
[Musique]
alain schick à faire le parcours et voir
ce que cela donne
et nous voilà partis avec alan penn pour
une démonstration après laquelle vous ne
verrez plus votre grande surface de la
même manière
prenez le rond point à l'entrée est ici
il faut dire que sa thèse est au point
c'est en se rendant des dizaines de fois
dans ce magasin de londres qu'il a pu la
tester
[Musique]
nous le suivons en caméra discrète
selon le professeur toute la stratégie
du géant suédois repose sur ce système
de flèches au sol si elle n'existait pas
nous serions totalement perdue par le
plan volontairement compliquées du
magasin
pourriez vous me dire dans quelle
direction et l'entrée où est garée la
voiture c'est dans quelle direction
pointé du doigt
aucune vous n'en savez rien parce qu'on
tourne en rond selon le professeur pour
pouvoir mieux guider les clients à sa
guise dans un premier temps le magasin
les désoriente l'entrée du magasin si je
veux la rejoindre c'est par où à votre
avis
l'entrée du magasin où l'agencé
strictement rien peut-être là bas
impossible de se diriger par soi même
il faut faire confiance aux flèches
pourtant il existe bien des raccourcis
mais ils sont beaucoup moins bien
indiquée est le plus souvent ou les
passes sont les voir
[Musique]
le parcours là est évident vous allez
par ici et vous continuez à suivre les
flèches mais en fait sans le savoir vous
venez de passer un raccourci venez je
vais vous montrer effectivement nous
étions passés sans le voir à côté de ce
petit couloir et ce n'est pas par hasard
il n'y a aucune pancarte qui vous
l'indiquait le chemin de lui et très
clair donc on passe par là et lorsque
vous êtes si vous l'avez déjà dans le
dos vous ne voyez jamais si vous le
savez vous éviter toute une boucle des
raccourcis qui sont en fait destiné aux
vrais initiés du magasin les vendeurs
pour qu'il ne perd pas trop de temps
dans leurs déambulations et ce n'est pas
tout selon le professeur tout est fait
aussi pour compères de la notion du
temps les rayons sont aveugles ils n'ont
pas de fenêtre c'est comme dans un
casino c'est comme un as vegas qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire par là vous n'avez
aucune idée si c'est le jour ou la nuit
je ne pouvais pas voir l'extérieur et ça
ça vous désoriente totalement on ne
s'occupe plus du temps et on se laisse
guider par les flèches le magasin peut
concentrer toute notre attention sur ce
qu'il veut qu'on achète des accessoires
à petit prix sur lesquels on bute en
permanence dans les allées et qu'en
général on n'avait pas prévu d'acheter
vous avez 4 cintres pour un euro 30
ça coûte quelques centimes à fabriquer
ça vient peut-être de chine
c'est sans doute une marge à 1000% on
vient ici pour les prix imbattables sur
le mobilier et après on se fait plaisir
sur les autres offres presque rien je
dépense 100 euros sur un lit et là c'est
seulement 1 euro 30 d'accor
j'en prends 4 alors
voilà comment selon le professeur le
géant suédois parviendrait à nous faire
quitter ses magasins avec deux tiers
d'arctic en plus que prévu et ainsi
année après année la marque ne cesse de
développer ses magasins